[Música]
qué sabemos de georgia
situada entre el océano atlántico
florida y carolina del norte y carolina
del sur georgia se encuentra en el
corazón del sur de eeuu
yo ya es un estado de contrastes
montañas en el norte con la cordillera
de los apalaches y llanuras en el sur
con 10,6 millones de habitantes georgia
es uno de los estados más poblados del
país la mayoría de la población se
concentra en el norte en la región de la
capital
atlanta atlanta es además el centro de
la economía del estado cde de
importantes compañías como pies delta
airlines y cocacola la comunidad
afroamericana está muy presente en
george 33% de la población del estado
también es el lugar de nacimiento del
movimiento de derechos civiles el
electorado está bastante dividido
mientras que los hombro americanos y los
votantes graduados blancos votan a los
demócratas las áreas rurales tienden a
ser republicanas georgia también alberga
una gran población de cristianos
evangélicos un electorado clave para el
donald trump georgia ofrece 16
el colegio electoral en 2016 donald
trump ganó con el 54% de los votos el
estado no ha votado por un candidato
demócrata desde bill clinton en 1992
[Música]